elle aussi un post it sur son ordinateur
sous lesquelles était écrit paris ça
fait un an presque jour pour jour ce
documentaire qui nous a tous trouble et
vire à l'envers ses documentaires de
l'homme d'affaires alexandre taillefer
pour mieux comprendre les raisons qui
avaient poussé son fils de 14 ans à
mettre fin à ses jours
c'est un reportage qui a mis en lumière
la détresse chez les jeunes qui a aussi
donné naissance à un nouveau projet le
projet dit moi qui veut venir en aide
aux jeunes de 12 à 17 ans pour en parler
ali neveu directeur général de 10 mois
et jean-christophe pelchat influenceurs
bonjour à vous deux bonjour alors qu'en
est il exactement de cette plateforme
dix mois qu'est ce que c'est en fait
c'est une plate forme qu'on soit
déployée dans toutes les écoles du
québec les écoles secondaires et qui va
permettre d'aller sonder l'humeur des
jeunes d'être dans leur vie
régulièrement pour faire un peu
d'introspection puis lorsqu'ils auront
besoin
dead qui ont des enjeux des
préoccupations mais les guider vers les
bonnes ressources ça fonctionne
commandes de façon concrète web est
aujourd'hui sous sa forme actuelle c'est
un agent conversationnel un chat bottes
comme on dit donc dans messenger c'est
les jambes je peux me faire régner un
ami facebook dans messenger
donc c'est un robot qui interagit avec
le jeune régulièrement me demander
comment ça va aujourd'hui avec des
émoticônes ça va bien je suis triste
mais selon sa réponse on la mène un peu
plus loin dans la réflexion et
éventuellement l'encourager à venez
parler de ces anges donc cette
plateforme qu'un adolescent peut aller
télécharger s'ils le souhaitent si je
comprends bien et c'est un projet pilote
actuellement dans deux écoles jean
christophe quel est votre rôle vous dans
un mois après je travaillais avec annie
un peu à développer comment comprendre
ça que ça c'est pour les jeunes ou
comment composer attrayant pour les
jeunes qu'est ce que parce que l'enfant
on veut pas développer une plateforme
qui est un peu un look and feel con con
qu'on n'aimerait pas que les gens
or paul goude allait utiliser des
convois rendent aussi ses robots l'heure
peu plus friendly puis saleilles pas
trop de trucs au repos si on veut et
qu'on travaille à développer sans cesse
que ça fonctionne bien dans les projets
pilotes entre autres ils étaient plantés
au collège saint lambert valech du
rocher également l'école armand-corbeil
à terrebonne internationaux en fait
c'est c'est au delà de nos espérances
les résultats on a eu 115 jeunes pendant
un mois qui ont été raji presque
quotidiennement avec la plate forme est
sûre ces 115 jeunes l'ont dans notre 13
qui sur la durée du pilote
petit à petit sont arrivés à appeler à
l'aide
donnez des confidences parfois au robot
parfois en clavardant avec des
intervenants de l'école ou même en lien
direct avec tel jeunes parce que sur la
plateforme tous et yellow peuvent se
faire parce qu'il a fallu les convaincre
d'adhérer à south aspect naturellement
comment ça c'est comment ça c'est un
produit tout c'est ce qui est le plus
beau dans la personnalité de notre robot
c'est qu'il ya une approche jeunes et
qui tranquillement vient faire son
chemin auprès du jeune et il en a
confiance et avez-vous la
jean-christophe mais oui je pense qu'on
travaille aussi avec les bonnes
personnes pour le rend attrayant pl je
pense que les bons porte parole derrière
soi aussi tranquillement pied beaucoup
de jeunes beaucoup d'autres de mes amis
france a aussi commencé à s'entourer
au delà de ce fait autour de cette façon
là aussi d'en parler en bien fait si ça
l'est les jeunes a accepté de parler là
dessus même si avec les influences à
reçoivent eux mêmes de nombreux de
nombreuses confidences et sont un peu
pris avec ses confidences c'est pas des
experts en santé mentale
donc c'est aussi pourquoi il cherche à
venir s'impliquer avec dix mois nous on
est on a beaucoup de professionnels
derrière tout ça donc à la fois sa
valeur
les ied dans ce qu'ils vivent au
quotidien et au lion le contact avec les
jeunes c'est ça ça devenait on cherche
des recevants des témoignages comme
celui là et ne pas savoir quoi faire
exactement bien et bien aiguillé la
personne pas exactement
exactement c'est un peu cela la mission
du mois et d'un autre plateforme aussi
qu'on travaillait
développer puis c'est d'abord des
ressources parce qu'on est ce qu'on peut
lire envoyer facilement puis ils vont
prendre en charge ces jeunes le plus
envoyés par les bonnes personnes
par la suite est ce que l'on veut faire
alexandre d'affaires joue un rôle dans
le déploiement de la plateforme mais en
fait alexandre est toujours disponible
quand on en a à qui on veut avoir accès
à lui ils nous supportent toulon comme
coach d'arles dans le développement de
la pièce c'est quoi la prochaine étape
parce que c'est d'aller rencontrer le
ministre de l'éducation ça serait
extraordinaire je pense que mais on
attendait d'avoir des résultats concrets
ce qu'on nomme maintenant je pense que
c'est un projet de société
c'est un projet pour choix pour aider
longeant l appel est lancé
probablement entendu merci à vous
d'avoir et la semaine merci nous avons
reçu